today I want to show you a game that I
invented I think it's pretty fun to give
it a little test spin and if it is fun
well expect to see more videos of it
prisoners I'll see some orange in here
orange bellies that game is called
prison break nerf the way it works is we
have contraband drugs prisoner drugs
also known as gum and what we're going
to what you don't know that contraband
hey nothing officer ID it was not even
mine my friend is my friend I'm holding
for my friends and we will secretly be
holding on to this we'll pass it around
every is going to take one piece of gum
and chew on it prisoners win all the
prisoners are chewing gum and the person
holding the pack gum has not been shot
by the prison guards the prison guards
win if they shoot the person who's
holding the contraband the pack of gum
it's just one piece of gum doesn't count
yet to be holding this to get shot if
the prison guards shoot the wrong person
that prison guard is fired so the prison
guards effectively have two tries
because there's two prison guards let's
go give it a shot
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys so a big announcement for
you that all our big supporters and fans
are gonna enjoy
I'm not very good at playing guitar
knocking at the same time some Christian
has all the details for you we're gonna
reveal it later in this video so stay
tuned hey Gabe
where are we going today your wife has a
company right yeah we're gonna see where
all these indigo shirts come from
they're always in the background instead
Nico videos see you sure this mates with
a lot of different people yeah
artists workspace there's a bunch of
other guys you just pretty much rant a
little spa sectioned off parts of the of
the warehouse so there's like little
studios so we have we have the big spot
very sweet dude Gabe I'm excited I can't
wait for you to show us around yeah I
kind of wish you guys could see it at
night one of these the small studio we
actually used to rent so there it's a
metal frame with just yeah there's
basically two paper walls
basically yeah there are painters
pretty cool spot that's scared of the
headless woman
Cynthia loves plants my wife Cynthia she
wants to have like maybe look like a
jungle well now I'm not working that
corridor I'm working here or teaching or
doing freelance work wait what do you
teach again illustrator illustrator
you're an official teacher at a
university
I'm not even officially a teacher they
don't process my paperwork but still
haven't gotten paid for like five weeks
of work I'm hoping all that money just
comes in all I want we know Renzi bill
he's gonna start so we have to come to
Rend okay the piece of County then make
sure that all five of us get it to go by
the end of this okay just one in there
no I didn't go into the pen I've Danis
my seller right you're trying to pass
through security just like he says in
the movie blow he's like you gotta think
of something that's totally unrelated to
what you're doing and think about every
detail it's more than nice what about a
new strategy what if we left it
somewhere and then someone picked it up
instead of an actual path so you may
look for two weeks making fake passes
but we keep setting one out as on Harry
hey I can't see very well hold on right
here every time we pass it we get in
groups of three yeah it's always a three
pack subscribe it's trying to play it
cool if you just see that outline of
that contraband in the pocket hey is
that contraband in your pocket are you
just happy to see your friends want some
real snuggly prisoners over here hey
slow down
come on there's just a little bit closer
in the eye and we always throw previous
gum chores in the mix like yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
the way I won the first time ins I saw
who was chewing gum and so I realized
like it's one of those two goos must've
never show anyone if you're chewing gum
[Music]
[Applause]
so this is the first time I've been to
your studio is really cool see I know
almost nothing about making t-shirts I
know that you put like paints on some
sort of screen and you press it into a
t-shirt and then profit okay it's not
that simple so normally I would show
them the t-shirt selection the fabric
and go through with like inks what kind
of technique and then we'll go down with
artwork look make sure the artwork is
suitable for screen printing and then we
go ahead and do films and then we print
and get the order out pick out some
t-shirts that go through the process
okay this staircase is literally ratchet
straps to the the framework of the
building a mini voyage oh this is so
classy that's all teacher selection so
you guys could kind of like book through
it and see what like it's like very
artisan it's not like your average mass
production of printing t-shirts you just
you just stalk nice shirts literally
like burn the shirt with like acid or
something oh no way okay so you dispose
the body this one hidden like this is
what we use French films huge Epson and
we have it set to just black ink and
clear film and then we're gonna use this
to burn it on that screen so the emotion
that you're actually putting on the
screen print is it's reacting to the
light passing through it and that black
part of the film is stopping that light
yes it's literally like classic
photography we're going to like the the
Red Room and just like do all your
photos and stuff we are in exposure so
this is what can allow us to burn our
image onto our school
what is the grain that I'm sleeping so
this is actually glue and it's the
emulsion depending on the kind of
emulsion you use or the kind of
treatment that you're doing you'll apply
this this emulsion on to your screen let
it dry and then you can go ahead and
burn your image onto your screen looks
like just like a that's too light it's
like a reactive chemical exactly okay
this isn't actually part of the emulsion
we're seeing right now this is this is
just a black coming through this is just
see-through enough that were actually
seeing the clear plastic
karashi on the other side of it now that
I have my screen position you want to
make sure that it's sitting flat down
because right now the vacuum is gonna
turn on its gonna apply pressure
[Applause]
and once you have a printed sheet you
can just keep that in your inventory
forever exactly and it's best to keep
them stored away in the dark because if
you expose this to the life and I'll
start getting them Brown if you guys
like this shirt I'm wearing we actually
have a merch store with a bunch of cool
Cordura shirts you can check it out at
corridor digital comm slash store we
just keep our eyes peeled but they're
gonna try to like thank you sir I'm not
trying to figures out so we have just go
to the telltale signs I'm trying to
think of how do we tell somebody's
actually chewing gum and what's gonna be
like a real-ass I think there's a couple
things that we did well last time that
worked pretty well number one the
Triforce Triforce gum only gets past
what we need to figure out those like I
was the last one how about I didn't know
I was the last I mean the game just kind
of ended but like I didn't know if I had
to pass it and that I didn't know who
else was going to so we need to maybe
have like then the order I don't know
I'm just gonna go off instinct like all
right absolutely sure whoever I don't
like I used to be a prison guard
actually I killed me too you can you can
tell when the prisoners are seeking
somebody out it's surprisingly obvious
we were doing pretty good at doing the
past seven
I don't know how hard it's gonna be to
tell but I feel like now that we've done
it like three times we've been the
prisoners oh yeah that's the best way
[Music]
never we talk keep your hand over your
mouth oh I like that I like that lets
your mouth close and tell you're talking
every once in a while though we should
probably all just be like Sam's big
chewing other people
[Music]
[Applause]
I put the gun in my pocket but I
actually put it in
[Music]
to make sure that there isn't any
emulsion still here is anything that
shouldn't be there
allow the light to come through and you
can check for pinholes so then we can
just go ahead and let the screen dry but
we never expected to start screamin
accompany it just happen so I mean I
wasn't sure if you guys had a Pantone
number so I mixed yellow C specific
formulas for ain't you'll see we'll have
how many grams to use to mix this color
I have formulas that I use so I made the
yellow that we use for that made an
orange which is more of a dark yellow
and then a darker orange since we're
gonna be doing discharge we have to add
an activator so you like sure a little
point with that with the color yeah
exactly
bottom of the shirt
it's like renaissance-era paint bb-8
okay okay so this is like what is this
machine and what is it doing to the
t-shirt it's a dryer and it has multiple
heating panels that have actually four
heating panels the purpose of this is to
dry the ink or to heat the key thing to
cure it okay so you're actually curing
me yeah this really reminds me of
getting a sandwich and there's the
fresh-baked shirt what's for dinner that
took like almost no time either
discharged ink feels a little bit stiff
on your first print but once you wash
you seem really really soft literally in
the fabric it's like the difference
between a real tattoo and like a henna
tattoo yeah you could just wash it off
but it doesn't wash off luckily made
some really cool stuff for you guys Oh
what kind of ink is this
that's a discharge it's a water-based
ink with an activator that essentially
acts like a bleach answer the kind
what's the benefits of that specific
thing well it feels a lot softer and
it's permanent on your shirt it doesn't
crack instead of tags yeah we did custom
labels
/ well oh hey nice shirt Carmichael
thanks man
you literally just put that on
I did well thank you for stopping by
thank you guys so much
let me know if you give me any t-shirt
then yeah so where can we find you guys
you can get our website which is indigo
print Co comm or you could check out our
Instagram at indigo print Co Co and you
can contact you through Instagram
exactly yes this is super red oh we get
it with this sweet now yeah you know we
gotta do some storyboards so we gotta
get Gabe back to the studio so cut back
to the studio
your something important for you to know
we are making some major changes to our
corridor digital patreon page one we
have removed the live tutorials with red
2 we have an additional bonus under the
$5 tier but I'll get into more detail on
that shortly our 7 and $10 tears have
merged into one so now blooper reel
access and early access corridor digital
videos can all be had under 1 $7 tier
now for the big update our top two your
goal is an outfit adjusted to $7,500 a
month if we can exceed that goal every
month you will get a completely
exclusive Sam and Nico vlog we won't
upload it to the YouTube channels
instead we'll deliver it directly to you
guys the patrons if you want more
content want more vlogs go check out our
patreon page all you have to do is
pledge at least $5 to get that extra
monthly vlog that will be seen nowhere
else all right so the details we're
doing a big new patreon update for all
you guys who's gonna make some more
exclusive content for our fans for the
people that support us because you guys
make this all possible
especially in a day and age where
advertising revenue is up in the air who
knows how that whole system is gonna
work next year so if you really enjoy
our work you want to support it make it
keep happening
and you want an extra vlog every month
go check out our patreon campaign link
in the description below and honestly
it's super cool because like the whole
patron thing started back in Italy and
the Renaissance when
the rich merchants want to help fund the
arts and make them something worthwhile
as we came out of the Dark Ages this is
like the digital equivalent to that you
can help make art a reality yeah good
stuff
[Music]
we're gonna tar